good news for the country's worst hit by
coronavirus
regulators approved the first vaccine
for rollout
following a similar green light in the
uk today our nation has achieved a
medical
miracle we have delivered a safe and
effective vaccine in just
nine months this is one of the greatest
scientific accomplishments
in history it will save millions of
lives and soon end the pandemic
once and for all the first vaccine will
be administered in less than 24 hours
developing the pfizer bioentech vaccine
was one feat
rolling it out across the united states
is another
dry ice a useful part of the logistics
chain
it's got to be kept at negative 94 so
dry ice is negative 109 so it's a
perfect
transportation device to put in the
boxes for the vaccine
it's just a problem of logistics
cold storage at hospitals also key
hospital workers treating covert
patients will be among the first to
receive the jab
i'm very excited for this and i think
you know america is ready for this
uh big thing now is to make sure that
the general public is educated
as to the pros and cons of the vaccine
encourage everyone
to research as much as possible all of
those things don't take all your
information
from facebook and instagram go out
and seek out information from some
credible sources
trust in the vaccine will be vital if
science is going to end the pandemic
with the us death toll from covert 19
approaching 300 thousand people
that can't happen soon enough debra
haynes sky news washington